cette vidéo est sponsorisé par kambly
une application de cours d'anglais à
distance avec des locuteurs natifs on
peut même les trier en fonction de leur
accent et tous et bonnart on en reparle
en fin de vidéo
faut qu'on parle de la pire harmach de
ce siècle juste après parcours sucre et
le jus de fruits étiquetés sans gluten
serait sans doute entendu des
associations ou des entreprises qui se
vante de planter des arbres pour lutter
contre le changement climatique si ton
voisard air france le groupe psa toyota
audi heureuse par shell eni total energy
starbucks display ou codées slate ou
yves rocher on a aussi des programmes de
plantation menées par des
arrêtés et les gouvernements et
institutions s'ils sont aussi mis de
l'allemagne avec son beau challenge mais
aussi la commission européenne la
nouvelle zélande avec son one bil in
trees fera mieux que le one beliën on a
le onetwo et les cuisiner tu étais dans
lequel s'est engagé l'administration
américaine qui dit mieux les chinois
avec leurs graines for green c'est le
programme de reforestation le plus
ambitieux que jamais conclut le quai
1999 la chine y aura investi 66
milliards de dollars pour planter 28
millions d'hectares de forêts du public
au privé tout le monde s'il ya même un
moteur de recherche qui propose de
planter un arbre dans un pays du sud dès
que vous taper des mots comme strapontin
onguents scrotum et et aussi tous les
autres
la vraie question qui se pose c'est à
quel point tous ces gens de prend-il
pour des sept initiatives numéro un
quand il s'agit de s'engager en faveur
du climat est elle vraiment les gîtes ou
bien on va voir tout de suite ce qu'on
dit la sionge actuellement on a à peu
près planté 80 millions d'arbres
[Applaudissements]
le petit arbre doit faire petit mais
vous au sol
débutons séance tenante par un brin
d'histoire voulez-vous l'idée de planter
des arbres pour compenser ses émissions
de co2 remonterait au moins à 1977 quand
le physicien et mathématicien freeman
dyson qui a décidément bien une tête
d'anglais a écrit cette étude il y dit
bon les gars alors comme vous le savez
déjà en brûlant des combustibles
fossiles à l'appel comme on le fait on
ouvre la rgpp l'un de co2 dans
l'atmosphère ce qui réchauffe rapidement
de clim si j'étais vous je planterai
pléthore d'armes pour au contraire
qu'ils prélèvent ce carbone de
l'atmosphère et le stock ce qui est
assez ironique c'est que ce beau
gaillard un peu viré climato sceptiques
je sais pas pourquoi ni quand ni comment
mais deux cuillerées critiqué la
propagande du réchauffement climatique a
affirmé qu'on ne pouvait pas croire les
modèles et aussi que finalement une
augmentation de co2 dans l'atmosphère
pouvait faire plus de bien que de mal
[Musique]
il était aussi membre d'un lobby fier
matos éthique notable en angleterre donc
c'est cocasse de penser que la solution
numéro uno qu on dégaine pour lutter
contre le changement climatique
aujourd'hui émane d'un climato
sceptiques sur le tard mais fermons
cette parenthèse drolatique pour en
revenir à l'information principale les
arbres stocks du carbone prélevés dans
l'atmosphère pour pas mal d'économistes
le ferais serait même l'un des puits de
carbone les plus rentables qui soit et
ça c'est comme le cheval c'est génial en
france métropolitaine l'inventaire
forestier national a calculé que nos
16.5 millions d'hectares de forêts
permettait de séquestrer non pas en
selle et gretel mais 13 8 millions de
tonnes de carbone par soit environ 11 %
de nos émissions actuelles bon alors ça
y est on peut planter un cyprès au fond
du jardin et continuer à faire des
drifts ans et suivez sur le parking de
truffaut alors pas vraiment c'est qu'il
ya des petits problèmes dans nos
plantations revenons-en l'hypothèse de
base du truc qui est les arbres sont des
puits de carbone alors qu'ils ont tous
trois à cacia et sauvant clément et ben
c'est pas si simple les ja il faut
savoir que le carbone entre et sort des
forêts il y entre via la photosynthèse
qui permet aux plantes de stocker le
carbone du co2 atmosphérique dans leur
tronc leurs branches et leurs racines
mais en échange des forêts et mettent
aussi du co2 en respirant aussi bien les
végétaux même que les bestioles qui
dorment sous les frondaisons ce dont on
s'est aperçu notamment grâce à des
instruments qui s'appelle les tours à
flux qui sont des trucs préférées juste
pour le nom parce qu'en vrai c'est un
peu je sais que une forêt va capter plus
de carbone qu'elles n'en rejette quant à
elle est en pleine croissance dès
qu'elle est mature elle en captera mois
et du coup son rôle de puits de carbone
est beaucoup moins évident mais les
vieilles forêts sont quand même super
intéressantes sur plein d'autres aspects
notamment la biodiversité non à l'âgisme
végétales par contre même si les flux
s'équilibre à la longue et que les
forêts matures pour leur âge n'aspirent
plus trop de co2 en grandissant les
arbres se sont bel et bien constituer un
stock de carbone dans leur intimité et
donc c'est pas vraiment le fait d'avoir
une forêt qui va nous aspirer le carbone
qu'on aimait en prenant l'avion pour
faire paris lille mais c'est plutôt
celui d'augmenter les surfaces arboré et
donc de faire pousser de plus en plus de
forêts d'emblée vous voyez pendant un
petit souci lui que la terre n'est pas
extensible et qu on a aussi besoin des
surfaces pour faire d'autres trucs que
planter des pins pour compenser
l'empreinte carbone du moc acino lait
d'ânesse que vous buvez chaque matin en
lisant votre society quelqu'un dit
society s'est pas remis mais c'est pas
tout parce que de toute façon ce que je
vous ai présenté c'est une vision un peu
tronquée de la chose s'intéressant au
stockage du carbone dans les arbres
c'est négliger tout ce qui se passe dans
l'écosystème tout entier et notamment
sous terre et manque de bol si ce qui
importe le plus les seuls stocks deux à
trois fois plus de carbone que les
plantes au dessus et voilà vous faites
par les théologies spies est fier de
vous en plus entre les sols et la
végétation s'est justement les sols les
réservoirs de carbone les plus stables
puisque le carbone petit respect pendant
plusieurs centaines et non pas dizaine
d'années donc c'est cool d'augmenter la
quantité de carbone stockée sur terre
mais le vrai défi c'est d'accroître
celles stockées sous terre la france a
d'ailleurs lancé lors de la cop 21 en
2015 un programme international baptisé
4 pour 1000 qui vise à augmenter chaque
année la teneur en carbone des sols de 4
pour mille donc 0 4% comme quoi ils ont
l'air de savoir ce qu'ils font des fois
hélas vous interjetté tout de go dis
donc jean fleurons les plantations
d'arbres ou permettait justement
d'augmenter la quantité de carbone
stockée dans les sols et bien ma chère
adolphine rillettes c'est pas gagné le
vrai problème c'est qu'en général les
endroits qu'on choisit pour planter nos
forêts sont des écosystèmes ouvert comme
des prairies des savanes des tourbières
ou des stades 6e pour le coup stocks
plus de carbone que les forêts qu'on
veut y coller sans parler de la
biodiversité qu'ils abritent regardait
comme il est bien noir de carbone ce
joli seule la sole
donc si vous plantez des arbres dans ces
écosystèmes ouvert et surtout si vous le
faites avec les fraises ou escales de
perturber l'équilibré fragile des sols
et qu'ils se mettent à relarguer leur
précieux carbone directement dans
l'atmosphère telle une flatulence
playmate au tragique au le bilan
environnemental de votre mac à chino
s'est alourdi moralité les forêts sont
peut-être pas les écosystèmes les mieux
indiqué pour atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques ce qui soulève la question
pourquoi diable vouloir nous coller des
forêts partout comme le dit le dernier
rapport du giec c'est pas parce qu'un
arbre peut pousser un endroit qu'il doit
y être il ya un autre effet secondaire à
cette histoire de planter des arbres
dans des écosystèmes mal adapté c'est
que les prairies et compagnie réverbère
davantage la lumière du soleil que le
couvert forestier qui est de couleur
plus foncée et donc si vous décorer la
planète avec des forêts là où il y en
avait pas avant c'est comme si vous en
finir un tee-shirt noir vous plaît
mettez vous à les absorber davantage la
lumière du soleil et en définitive
augmenter la température de surface en
tout cas dans certains milieux et ça
c'est exactement l'inversé de ce que
vous voulez faire à la base à titre
d'exemple au chili des chercheurs ont
observé une step se faire grignoter par
la forêt sur une dizaine d'années en
conséquence l'albédo c'est à dire cette
réverbération de la lumière du soleil a
diminué de 20% ça veut dire que le
couvert végétal a absorbé 20 % d'énergie
en plus en outre l'intérêt et
l'efficacité de la manoeuvre va dépendre
des plantes qu'on une plante souvent on
prend la première promo qui vient chez
jardiland c'est des espèces exotiques
donc pas du coin est très souvent
invasif par dessus le marché de sa tout
un tas de conséquences potentiellement
désastreuses puisqu'elles peuvent
déséquilibrer les écosystèmes et menacer
la survie des espèces locales et tant
qu'à faire mais les plantes en
monoculture c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
dans le programme chinois dont je vous
parlais au début ça c'est pas bon du
tout pour la biodiversité imaginez un
immense supermarché qui ne proposerait
que des silhouettes taille réelle de
cyril féraud dans les rayons vous ne
verriez que des sexagénaires en robe à
fleurs avec un cabas à roulettes et moi
probablement une bonne là c'est pareil
si vous voulez une grande variété de
clients c'est-à-dire de bestioles en
tous genres proposés une grande variété
de produits phares de végétaux mais
c'est pas tout si vous planter une forêt
sur un sol pas fait pour elle risque de
siphonner vos nappes phréatiques et
d'assécher vos cours d'eau ben oui les
arbres ça boit et ça transpire comme mon
tonton gérard
des fois ça ne pose aucun problème et
les arbres aide même à améliorer la
qualité de l'eau mais d'autres fois ça
coince particulièrement dans les zones
arides où la ressource en eau est rare
et précieuse sans blague du coup une
plantation un convenu peut vous à sécher
tout le barda ce qui peut créer des
banques pour la nature mais aussi pour
l'agriculture et les villes et aux joies
en conséquence ça exacerbe aussi le
risque incendies est oui moins d'eau
plus de feu et puis les milieux arides
sont livrés avec des starter pack
d'espèces habitué aux incendies qui
savent y faire et se remette vite et des
fois elles ont même besoin de ces feux
là pour se développer des plantes asie
une monoculture de pain ou d'eucalyptus
des trucs qui flambent vite et bien et
vous voici avec beaucoup trop de bougies
sur le gâteau d'anniversaire qu'est la
planète demandez aux portugais non c'est
pas le début d'une blague raciste c'est
ce que je vous dis là c'est un exemple
pas pris au hasard du tout puisque c'est
d essence très utilisé est le cadeau qui
va avec c'est qu'en brûlant les arbres
largue tous leurs précieux carbone dans
l'atmosphère retour à la case départ
ensuite plante un arbre c'est bien
mignon mais il devient quoi après parce
que si c'est juste pour le déraciner
aussi sec et en faire du petit bois ou
de la pâte à papier ça nous fait une
belle jambe que vous plantez des arbres
pourriez aussi annoncé qu à chaque café
acheté vous vous engagez à un pondre un
oeuf ou à caresser une limite donc que
deviennent les arbres si notre prospère
si notre prospère forêt gaiement si
notre fort et prospère guillemant génial
c'est parfait mais vous me voyez venir
c'est rarement le cas elle peut aussi
être coupés ou fournir du bois comme
vous le cramer pas aussi sec c'est bon
c'est qu'à chaque le carbone de
l'atmosphère est maintenant piégés dans
les murs de votre chalet votre table
climax est votre plan de travail free
débile et q7 une super idée troisième
possibilité est malheureusement la plus
courante ça tourne mal les ferai pas ce
l'arbre à gauche - oui suffit pas de
planter un truc pour qu'ils traversent
les âges c'est tout un art si on
n'intervient pas les plantations peuvent
entre autres se faire décimer par des
pathogènes des insectes ravageurs de la
sécheresse ou des incendies c'est ce qui
s'est passé au sri lanka après le
tsunami de 2004 13 millions de dollars
ont été investis pour restaurer la
mangrove plus de cinq ans plus tard
moins de 10% des arbres plantés dans les
trois quarts des sites avaient survécu
notamment parce qu'il ya eu aucune
surveillance ni maintenant dans le même
genre des chercheurs ont étudié une
région de l'inde dans laquelle les
plantations étaient tellement fait avec
les pieds que plus de la moitié du
budget investi par l'état a été gaspillé
sans parler des moyens humains qui vont
avec et vu le petit aperçu que j'ai eu
la littérature scientifique ces deux
exemples me paraissent loin d'être des
cas isolés malheureusement
ce qui est important je crois c'est de
soutenir des personnes qui veulent faire
du bien
jusqu'à maintenant pas braquer tout le
monde dès le début mai avec un sujet
pareil je peux pas ne pas parler de
politique je suis désolé ce serait comme
aller à la piscine sans portée des crocs
ou regarder la saison 6 de camelot sans
se crever les us et les pratiques de
boisement et de reboisement se sont
multipliés ces derniers temps c'est
grâce au protocole de kyoto c'est un
accord absolument fondamental dans la
lutte contre le changement climatique
qui a été signé en 1987 pas du tout à
1997 pas 184 et en vise à limiter la
quantité de gaz à effet de serre qu'on
aimait dans l'atmosphère jusqu'ici ce
louable c'est à la suite de ça qu'on se
dit aimer j'ai une idée de génie on va
mettre en place un système de crédits
carbone chaque pays n'a droit qu'à un
certain quota de gaz à effet de serre
qui peut émettre chaque année super
comme cela sauf que la magie vie
capitaliste ceux qui n'utilisent pas
tous leurs crédits carbone peuvent les
revendre à d'autres et paf sous vos yeux
ébahis mais un nouveau marché la petite
astuce c'est que planter des arbres nous
donne durable de crédits carbone du coup
ce qui s'est passé c'est que les pays du
nord ont donné de la tuna ce pays du sud
pour qu'ils plantent des arbres pour eux
et disposer ainsi de leurs crédits
carbone c'est tout à fait légal 1 on
appelle ça le mécanisme de développement
propre
je n'invente rien comme ça les pays
riches ont pu continuer à polluer à
disposer de leurs terres comme ils le
souhaitent et ils ont profité des prix
très compétitifs offertes par les pays
en voie de développement et en retour
les pays du sud ont profité d'une
rentrée d'argent et ils ont plus engagés
dans la lutte finale contre le
changement climatique c'est win win
voilà ça c'est un discours des
institutions sauf que quand on réfléchit
un peu basse allait pas du tout in win
certains qualifient même sa de
colonialisme du carbone ce pas moi qui
l'ait dit certains se disent est ce que
finalement tout ça ce serait pas un
moyen pour les pays riches d'éviter
d'assumer leurs responsabilités
historiques et de faire payer le prix de
leur pollution ou plus pauvres et aux
écosystèmes les plus menacées encore une
fois c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
certain claude certains il est
éditorialiste au mensuel d où qu elles
soient là évidemment les pays du nord
plante aussi des arbres chez eux mais
c'est toujours bien de garder en tête la
réalité associés à ce programme de
compensation carbone en lien avec le
protocole de kyoto programme qui est
loin d'être anecdotique et anodin et qui
va contribuer à renforcer les inégalités
sociales lorsqu'en général et ça c'est
un point ultra important ces projets là
ne sont pas faits en consultation avec
les populations locales c'est des trucs
que leur gouvernement leur impose en les
privant de leurs droits leur dis mon
petit bob des troupeaux qui pèsent sur
tes terres là ils sont bien mignon mais
il dégage pas ce qu'on va planter une
forêt et puis t'as plus le droit de
revenir on exproprie alors bob que
fait-il et bah déjà il est colère et
ensuite il va déplacer son bétail ou son
champ si l'agriculteur sur une parcelle
boisée à côté qui rasent au passage
c'est à dire qu'en voulant planter des
arbres en fait on aggrave la
déforestation on est d'accord c'est
complètement con un exemple qui illustre
assez bien cette non prise en compte des
populations indigènes c'est la zone de
conservation et de gestion du rio bravo
obélisque qui a été créée en 1995 les
populations natives qui vivaient dans
ces forêts ont été déplacés on les a
exproprié sans leur fournir la moindre
alternative qui vivait pourtant de
l'exploitation de leurs bois et de la
chasse voilà comment ces projets creuse
les inégalités sociales en privant les
locaux de leur propriété et de leurs
moyens de subsistance
par souci d'équité il est grand temps de
laisser la parole aux défenseurs de
cette pratique de plantation d'arbres et
pour aborder le sujet qui de mieux
placer qu'une fervente militante plantes
aux olympiques ma soeur jumelle morte
chemin
oui
merci fiona pour ce pamphlet engagés
dont on ne ressort pas indemne pour
résumer planter des arbres pour lutter
contre le changement climatique sa part
de la meilleures intentions mais c'est
ultra simpliste et c'est une solution
souvent inadéquate du point de vue
social économique et environnemental si
on plante les mauvaises essence au
mauvais endroit ça peut faire l'effet
inverse de ce qu on cherche est allé
jusqu'à rejeter du carbone dans
l'atmosphère faire grimper le mercure ou
diminuant l'albédo assécher les nappes
phréatiques accroître le risque
d'incendié appauvrir la biodiversité
locale et creuser les inégalités
sociales les forêts plantées et surtout
les monocultures d'espèces exotiques
sont aussi moins capable de s'adapter au
changement climatique que leurs
homologues nature est aujourd'hui les
scientifiques savent bien que non
planter des forêts n'est pas la solution
miracle pour lutter contre le changement
climatique c'est un des outils
disponibles parmi un arsenal assez vaste
d'initiative de conservation de la
nature et en plus ça coûte vachement
cher pour un taux de réussite pas jojo
surtout que le dernier volet du rapport
du giec qui vient de sortir a souligné
l'urgence climatique dans laquelle on
était on n'a pas le temps de gâcher nos
efforts en faites vous mieux faire tout
de suite qu'elle plus de chance de
marcher voici donc les vraies solutions
qui s'offrent à nous déjà on pourrait
commencer par chip à wavrin brûler des
combustibles fossiles ça c'est une idée
comme ça on aurait moins d'émissions de
carbone à compenser pensez-y quitté
l'instant gros cerveau non parce que il
ya un pas qu'on n'a pas encore abordé
c'est la stabilité des stocks si vous
planter une forêt pour compenser d'avoir
cramer du charbon par exemple nous
échanger du carbone issu d'un stock
extrêmement stable dans joue son rôle de
réservoir paix poussent depuis des
lustres plusieurs millions de lustre
même avec du carbone stocké dans une
tige qui tiendra quelques dizaines
d'années au mieux avant de retourner
dans l'atmosphère une fois que notre
bois sera flambé à son tour est ce qu'on
peut vraiment dire que c'est de stocks
sont équivalents alors que l'un est très
vulnérable aux aléas que l'autre est
beaucoup plus stable alors certes c'est
cool on enlève quand même du carbone de
l'atmosphère mais pour moi mon temps
m'est avis qu'il vaut mieux juste le
laisser willem carbone si on a le choix
ensuite face aux programmes de plantage
masse il vaut clairement mieux favoriser
les initiatives contre la déforestation
qui continuent d'aller bon train pendant
ce temps on perd plus de 10 millions
d'hectares de forêts chaque année soit
plus de huit mille milliards de pq mis
côte à côte ça fait beaucoup ce qu on
aura beau essayer tout ce qu'on peut
d'état d'études montrent que même le
meilleur programme de restauration ne
permettra jamais de retrouver le niveau
de biodiversité d'antan d'une forêt ce
sera perdu pour toujours alors quand je
lis des trucs comme la déforestation
atteint des records absolus donc aux
plantes des arbres je me dis que bah non
en fait c'est un raisonnement fallacieux
la réponse logique c'est de freiner la
dette les stations mieux vaut éviter les
dégâts plutôt que d'essayer de les
réparer après tout c'est à la fois plus
logique et plus efficace et c'est aussi
la solution la plus rentable en fait
c'est cool avec tous ces millions
économiser les grosses entreprises vont
pouvoir par exemple payer leurs impôts
en france seul choc comme tout à chacun
autre solution révolutionnaire si on est
dans une zone récemment déforester et
pas trop dégradée on peut tout
simplement laisser la forêt se régénérer
comme une grande n'y a pas plus
économique et la nature s'en sortira
mieux tout seul les graines dans le sol
vont germer les espaces autour vous
colonisé cet espace et les souches vont
émettre des rejets et youpi c'est ce qui
se passe en europe et y compris en
france suit en partie à la déprise
agricole et pastorale et aussi au
reboisement un peu quand même vous serez
contents d'apprendre que la forêt
française a presque doublé en deux
siècles à 100 de moins de 8 millions
d'hectares en 1830 à plus de 16 points 5
millions d'hectares aujourd'hui voilà
c'était la bonne nouvelle de la vidéo
j'espère que vous l'avez savourer et
j'étais pas vouloir passer en si vous
avez un petit coup et puis on peut
parler de restauration d'écosystèmes en
général sans pour autant que ce soit
forcément des forêts si vous voulez
restaurer des savanes surtout vous aimez
par d'ailleurs ça tombe bien en 2019
l'onu a déclaré deguire et
l'onu a déclaré qu'on entrait dans la
décennie des nations unies pour la
restauration des écosystèmes histoire
d'encourager partout sur terre les
initiatives qui vont dans ce sens c'est
une façon de lutter contre le changement
climatique de renforcer la biodiversité
la sécurité alimentaire et l'accès à
l'eau potable 4 en 1 mieux qu'une
lessive mais je suis pas là pour
diaboliser les arbres pour autant j'ai
un très bon ami ginkgo biloba les forêts
ses muses écosystème très chouette elles
permettent d'améliorer la qualité de
l'air et de l'eau de limiter l'érosion
des sols elle abrite une biodiversité
importante propose une large gamme de
biens immobiliers fournissent de l'ombre
dans les villes augmente notre bien-être
et font revenir les tripes bref vous
avez compris qu'une forêt c'est bien
plus que planté 2020 maritime tous bien
alignées et que ça peut nous rendre bien
des services aussi par exemple pour
dissimuler un cadavre comme l'a si bien
expliqué fiona tantôt plantait des
arbres ce n'est pas systématiquement
kaka tant que c'est bien fait d'ailleurs
je dis pas que tous les projets que j'ai
mentionné au début sont forcément à
jeter un de ceux des exemples parmi
d'autres sauf celui de total énergie et
donc si vous voulez soutenir
intelligemment ces pratiques assurez
vous d'abord que ce sont des essences
locales qui sont utilisés c'est à dire
des espèces natives que ce soit un
peuplement mélanger ou même un système
agroforestier ou agro sylvo pastorale en
tout cas pas un champ de cyril féraud
que le programme prévoit un suivi au
long terme de ces plantations sur
plusieurs années au moins et qu'elles
soient faites dans des eaux avait encore
une forêt ya pas longtemps le tout étant
imaginé deux concerts avec les
populations locales et qu'elles puissent
directement bénéficié de ce programme ça
a l'air tout bête comme ça mais ça
conditionne énormément le taux de
réussite de tout le projet la clé est en
notamment de doter les locaux de droit
décisionnel sur les terres parce qu'on a
vu que ce n'était pas toujours le cas
comme le disent les auteurs de cette
étude parue dans science en 20 ans cette
approche va certainement augmenter le
prix de la plantation mais c'est de
l'argent mieux dépensé que de simplement
planté des arbres dont la plupart ne
survivront pas et plutôt que de se fixer
un nombre d'arbres à planter ce qu'il
faudrait pas mieux juste considérer le
nombre d'arbres qui survivront après
plusieurs années de séminaire vous en
faites ce que vous voulez voilà
maintenant vous êtes parés pour savoir
quoi objecté à votre entreprise préférée
la prochaine fois qu'elle vous sortira
son meilleur élément greenwashing acheté
chez nous on plante des arbres
pour la sponsor du jour je vais faire ce
que j'aime le plus vous raconter ma vie
en bonne petite bourgeoise g ponctuée à
mes études d'une année de césure en
angleterre ça me faisait pas peur
j'avais 22 ans 11 ans de cours d'anglais
derrière moi en plus j'étais une bonne
élève donc belle j'y allais sereine et
bas les quinze premiers jours étaient
d'une violence folle je les comprenais
que pouic quand on me parlait je
trébuche et sur mes propres phrases et
j'ai plusieurs fois hésiter a juste
lâché la sphère est rentré en france
parce que c'était trop attention
spéciale quand j'ai dû faire des
démarches administratives en anglais
quand j'ai dû ouvrir un compte en banque
et discuter avec des agences pour louer
un appart puis j'étais une vraie petite
fragile en tout cas à l'époque j'aurais
adoré pouvoir me préparer à la réalité
du terrain pour justement méditer ce
moment douloureux de pouvoir m'entraîner
à comprendre l'accent des locaux par
exemple et c'est justement ce que
propose kambly nido qui complice est un
service de cours d'anglais en ligne en
fait on choisit un tuteur avec qui on
peut discuter pendant un temps donné ça
permet de se préparer à un examen un
voyage ou une immigration pardon on dit
expatriation je crois qu'on peut choisir
l'accent du tuteur sa personnalité mais
aussi notre propre niveau et changer
comme ça en direct avec un locuteur
natif ça permet d'apprendre des trucs
qu'on n'apprend pas en cours et ça
permet aussi de vaincre sa peur de
s'exprimer dans une langue étrangère et
comme je suis une vendre une personne
géniale je vous offre un cours d'essai
est une réduction magnifique sur votre
abonnement grâce aux codes fiona éolien
dispo en description de la vidéo car yes
you came blé
oui
l'asim chez ea petit mois dans les
commentaires pour vous habitez et
peut-être que je viendrais planter des
arbres chez vous peut-être